[Music]
opencast coal mining is a dirty business
and South Africa's coal mining hub in
Mpumalanga province has its fair share
of it most of the coal produced here is
used for the area's 11 coal-fired power
plants environmental activists Thomas
and Guney keeps a close eye on the side
effects of many coal-fired power plants
we have and the emissions that go out of
the power plants affect the grazing land
that is it's nearby and therefore
compromising the quality of the crops
which at the end of the day we consume
and ends up in our poorest here close to
an ash dump of the nearby power plant
lives
Rikka PACU and her small grandson that
has consequences for their health nearly
90% of South Africa's electricity is
generated using coal and despite effects
on human health the environment and food
security
two more coal-fired power stations are
currently under construction the more
these partitions
and mining operations exist in our
communities the more we get sick the
more we tie and the more we have to pay
and the more the food becomes expensive
the more we lose our land more than
three thousand people live beneath these
power lines close to the power station
yet they have no access to electricity
themselves the new plants are not going
to provide any changes for people they
don't have access to electricity now and
they will not have access to electricity
even in the future in sunny South Africa
with its abundance of windswept coasts
renewable energy solutions like so
and wind could provide a clean cheap and
sustainable alternative for this
community and for many others